it's time for seeing an unseen when we
reveal the stories behind the headlines
and for that we turn to the author of
the book the wise men who found
Christmas Fox News contributor Raymond
Arroyo all right Ray it was a rough
weekend for Hollywood at the box office
Laura it was the lowest box office Hall
since Thanksgiving of 1994. and leading
the Cineplex of Shame was a Disney film
appropriately called Strange World
Disney sold the film as an historic
first the first animated movie with a
gay lead who is a person of color but
for all that Interstellar inclusiveness
they even had a disabled dog it couldn't
save strange world
over five days it pulled in a mere 24
million dollars it cost them
180 million to make Laura now you know
why Bob chapek's out of a job well I I
don't understand why they just don't
focus on making great films a great
animated features or great films
everything has to be check this box and
check just make a great film make a
great story there's a family audience
that's obviously hungry they want
content but you've got to serve that
audience not your creative Community
whoever else you think you're pleasing
here obviously this isn't resonating
with the wider audience but look Disney
could have made Strange World lore as a
live action film when I saw this next
clip I thought we already live in a
Strange World this could be its own
horror movie imagine children having
lunch in Nantucket when suddenly outside
the window something creepy stirs
[Music]
some children taking video from a
restaurant could not contain their
excitement when they saw the president
walking by okay but we added the music
Laura for effect but I mean he does look
like a geriatric Norman Bates there I
mean who needs an Elf on the Shelf when
you have a Biden in the garden your kids
better be good or Uncle Joe's gonna come
and sniff you no joke no joke
yeah Corn Pop is going to get you too so
watch out that's a frightening image
maybe Corn Pop on the shelf that would
be more more interesting well look as
you know the president has said
challenges Laura with syntax over the
last few years well it seems whatever he
has his spokesman has now contracted it
today Karine Jean-Pierre extolled the
nobility of the prize formerly known as
Nobel
today President Biden met with three U.S
winners of the 2022 Nobel Prize Dr
Caroline bertozzi who won the Nobel
Prize in chemistry Dr John clauser who
won the Nobel Prize in physics and Dr
Douglas Diamond who won the Nobel Prize
in economic Sciences four times Laura in
a row she's the White House spokesman
the award's only been around since 1901.
uh you know Jean Baptiste is coming my
New Orleans uh Hometown boy he's coming
to play at the White House for the first
date dinner I hope she doesn't refer to
him as a Grammy winning artist you know
she's got to learn the names of basic
Awards uh Pulitzer Grammy Oscar and
Nobel maybe she at least she didn't
wasn't referring to the you know all the
exorbitant costs of living and she could
have called it a noble price you know so
thank goodness it was she got pry is
right so let's look at the positive here
I guess so I'm waiting for her to get
her own Emmy Award uh you'll remember a
while back Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau had a little trouble
expressing his LGBT allyship
I will never apologize for standing up
for an LGBT l-gt LBT
lgbtq 2 plus uh kids rights Trudeau is
making amends to plus following in the
pandering footsteps of political leaders
like Nancy Pelosi and AOC Trudeau has
made his drag race debut the people of
Canada must be so proud
do I have to kiss his rainbow I know
that this is the great white noise but
how do you feel about adding some brown
milk
okay you know what we do diversity
better than just about any other place
in the world hate to see you leave love
to watch and walk away
my goodness you know he's been facing
questions Laura over the use of
emergency measures he wasn't quite so
inclusive of those people those truckers
who blocked the roadways because of the
vaccine mandates uh he's being
questioned about that but he seems very
uh willing to be objectified by this
show pandering for votes it's a tough
way to go
Raymond did you have a nice Thanksgiving
we had a great Thanksgiving we're here
in New York with the whole family it was
wonderful uh I just the only ones I
missed were my mom and dad it's my
mother's birthday tonight so happy
birthday Mom happy birthday Mrs Arroyo
the royal family at the Macy's Parade I
saw those photos very very cool all
right Raymond good to see you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else